all right it is mailbag time well into
the depths of the mailbag as you can
imagine now uh towards the uh end of
January you can email info
davidpackman.com if you would like you
can also sometimes be featured in the
mailbag based on uh YouTube comments
Facebook messages tweets
not typically Tick Tock uh posts or
responses but maybe someday in any case
let's just jump right in because there
is so much meaty substance this week
Jeremy wrote in to me about critical
race Theory and Jeremy says David I've
been listening to your show for a while
now and you are so triggered about
critical race Theory you were in a
meltdown talking about Arkansas Banning
CRT in their schools honestly why are
you so upset about this if they
supposedly don't teach it in the first
place it seems like you support CRT in
schools I seriously want to know if you
do listen
um I am not melting down about what's
happening in Arkansas
I'm worried that a disastrous state is
just wasting money time and resources on
things that won't help them improve
education Arkansas is a disaster on
education I gave you all of the
statistics in my segment last week about
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Banning critical
race Theory what upsets me about it is
that the people of Arkansas
voted for someone who was clearly being
selected to do this type of nonsense
virtue signaling rather than fixing the
economy or getting jobs there or dealing
with the horrible educational numbers or
any of it she bans something that just
isn't happening and she claims to be a
small government conservative so I have
no plans to live in Arkansas I feel bad
for the people that that do in the sense
that it's not even just that culturally
I couldn't take it they have had a
string of leaders that just waste their
taxpayer money of which they don't
really have that much quite frankly
Arkansas very much depending on the
Federal Dole and do things that are just
a waste of time and money so it's not
that I'm melting down it's that it's a
terrible thing for the people of
Arkansas and I feel bad for them I feel
very very bad for them
um Trump uh D.L wrote in about Trump and
says why are you so obsessed with Trump
get over it you never talk about the
Biden crime family they have been
corrupt for over 40 years maybe because
of your age you didn't know this
but you could educate yourself now looks
like the Dems want him out he's a fool
even Obama mentioned it on tape Obama
I don't know what DL is talking about I
have no idea what he's talking about and
remember Biden crime family
investigate Biden for the classified
document stuff if there was wrongdoing
do whatever you need to do
but keep investigating Trump as well
because the situations are very
different Hunter Biden Hunter Biden did
something criminal or potentially
criminal law enforcement and the justice
department should investigate charge the
guy if he's guilty throw him in jail I
don't care
but for Republicans to make Hunter Biden
the foremost political issue is
disgusting Hunter Biden has nothing to
do with the Biden Administration unlike
Ivanka and Jared and so on
um and to take up Congressional time as
they plan to do
investigating Hunter give me a break
it's pathetic so I don't know what DL is
talking about but DL seems very very
triggered Justin wrote In Justin says I
treat your show like the news because
I'm not particularly fond of TV news
though I do watch other TV commentary
like Chris Hayes that Lawrence guy Ari
and others from MSNBC I actually
listened to all of them through clips on
YouTube you should have a segment on
your show where you cover multiple
recent headlining National and
international stories five to seven
offer quick commentary and move on to
the next thing you'd pick up people
looking for quick news you know we tried
this and nobody watched it there's this
interesting thing that happens and I
don't know if it's a blessing or a curse
I really don't Justin but sometimes when
you do your show a certain way for a
while
and you build an audience based on that
it's easy to think hey you know if I did
this other thing that other people have
success with I would just double My
Success I would do so so so well but
oftentimes when you test those things it
doesn't happen and I don't know the
reason why maybe it's because I've been
pigeonholed into doing the type of show
I do maybe it's because I wouldn't be
good at doing a five to seven story News
segment back for whatever reason when we
tried it nobody watched it I am always
interested in trying new formats and
ideas but that particular one didn't
work when we tried it in the past Dave
wrote in and says I enjoy watching your
YouTube posts that said it is quite
distracting when you're playing back
things and pause to make comments I'd
rather hear more of the video and then
hear your take on it so listen this has
been a disagreement among some of my
audience for a long time
I have taken the position based on what
I do
and the emails that I've received that
most people are watching this listening
to this
to hear my commentary now you could say
well fine but keep your commentary for
after the clip when I did that we tested
doing that I got a ton of emails from
people saying David you know I get that
news stations we'll often just play a
clip in its entirety and then like say
something later but the reason I'm
watching you is actually for you to
pause and break down break it down piece
by piece so David this is just a
preference and with peace and love I
appreciate that you don't like it every
time we've adjudicated this every time
we've investigated this the the
consensus is the majority not everybody
but the majority is David keep doing it
the way you do it when you want to pause
and tell us something about the clip let
us know Zachary wrote in now this one
this is tongue-in-cheek okay Zachary
says David I've been listening to your
show for years and the last few weeks
you've been talking about George Santos
and his supposed lies to think somebody
would spread such horrible claims about
the first man on the moon is sickening
not only that he is the president of the
United United States the king of England
and the world's tallest man
so have some respect you should be
ashamed of yourself David do better the
the king of England thing is funny I
once interviewed a guy named David
windmiller who since passed away may he
rest in peace
um and he David when Miller was known
for I believe he did anyway if he's
still alive then I apologize David when
Miller was known for t quote teaching
people to stuff their names full of
punctuation marks like semicolons and
dashes and stuff which he said would
make you non-taxable it didn't work
people would get thrown in jail for
contempt when they tried it but he
claimed that he was the king of Hawaii
um it was it was quite a ride I have to
tell you
uh but in any case
George Santos yes a very very honest man
Jeff wrote in and says good morning I
find it hypocritical that the people
questioning vaccines due to some
athletes having health issues are so
fast to dismiss why we are seeing once
in a generation weather events that seem
to be occurring monthly I'd like to hear
your thoughts thanks for the great
content
so let's here's the deal this is a very
common thing in politics left and right
do it but right now it's being
weaponized much more by the right
if you find an anomaly
and you want to use it to claim that it
is the status quo
you do it
and if you find an anomaly
and it is useful for it to be merely an
anomaly
then you say it's just an anecdote it's
just an anomaly and so although climate
science tells us that we should expect
exactly what we've been seeing extreme
high temperatures extreme low
temperatures weather events being more
serious more frequent hurricanes being
all these different things
that's not the story that works so they
say this is just whether it's not
climate forget about it whatever
on the other hand when it comes to
uh an expected number of young people
dying remember we went through the
numbers there has not actually been an
increase
they want to tell the story that it's an
epidemic because of the vaccine they
just do it uh the facts and the science
simply do not matter Andrew wrote In and
says Marjorie Taylor green on the
homeland security committee with
Marjorie Taylor green on this committee
asks Andrew should I as a Jew be
concerned about the investigation of our
space lasers listen Andrew
if they want to come and take the space
lasers that's one thing
but if Marjorie Taylor green comes from
my chocolate babka she will take it from
my cold dead hands that I guarantee you
sir
Michelle wrote in about trolls
speaking of which more comments tonight
from listeners who scorn you David I
find it astounding and sad that there
are so many people who have nothing
better to do than listen to podcasters
they dislike personally I struggle to
find time to keep up with the podcasters
and news sources that I like I can't
imagine wasting time following anyone I
disliked I guess some people just aren't
happy unless they're hating someone
hating on someone so sad yet this is a
really good point
I don't have the time to watch the shows
I want to watch to keep up with the
podcasts I like I don't have time for it
to read the books I want to read the
idea that I would waste any time with
the stuff I don't like is uh is
laughable but again these people have no
lives Michelle that's what you have to
remember info davidpackman.com if you
have something to say to me
say it to my face and I mean that by
email info davidpackman.com we have such
a great week of programs coming up for
you next week but we have the bonus show
first oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well many in our audience do
Alex you can sign up at joinpakman.com
let's make it a thing we'll see you then